for anyone who wants to learn
cinematography what are some of the best
exercises they can do
right now well if you're trying to learn
cinematography right now i mean
i would say take out your phone and just
shoot images and try to edit them
together
i think that's a bit a big part of
shooting at least for narrative but i
would assume this is true of
anything but i i'm more narrative is my
field
is the the way a sequence comes together
is a big part of my job it's not just
pretty images pretty images are great
they're really fun
but it's how you know i mean you know as
something as basic as wide shot
and a couple close-ups but getting used
to that watching
you know if you're filming a person this
was a big thing i remember when i
started to learn this and
working with when i was inexperienced
and working with inexperienced directors
and an actor would finish their last
line and then they'd start walking
his directors would always have me
follow them
and then there was no place to cut and i
realized like oh but if you let them
exit frame
and then you cut right there it's
cleaner as opposed to a moving shot that
then just
cuts and so you know our
phones are wonderful cameras they're
better than the cameras i started with
so
like i i there's no shame in shooting
with a phone when everybody's got one
so i think doing that but then yeah on
your phone they have editing programs or
whatever
so whatever is whatever you have at your
fingertips
use that but trying to
learn how something comes together i
mean i
i'm not super tick tock familiar but
i've seen some videos on there
and i have to say it's pretty incredible
watching some of the edits some of them
are unexpected
it's quick it's there's a rhythm to it
and i guess maybe that's
a part of it too is the rhythm of how a
sequence comes together so
i think shooting but more specifically
shooting and editing so that you see
what doesn't work because it's really
making mistakes that's how you're going
to get better is by screwing up
yeah how did you begin editing films
when you first
got your camera well let's see my first
when i
the first editing i did was super eight
so i guess that was you know
film and it was you i had this little
box where you cut it
and so you're i mean you're literally
holding up images and you're taping it
together
so i mean it's like proper old school
which really makes
you think about what you're shooting now
with digital
you know you can just shoot shoot shoot
and i think that can be i mean it's
wonderful
but it can be dangerous because you're
not making as many decisions ahead of
time
and i'm a believer in at least doing
things
thoughtfully and then experiment off of
that
uh but after that i mean i boy i think
i've edited every which way
i've edited on a flatbed edited film by
hand
i did uh what i had like a
a sketch comedy show i did at my local
cable access
and that was editing vhs to vhs
but you had to edit it linearly
so it wasn't non-linear edit so it was
you'd pick your shot from here and then
on this other i i
barely even remember it i remember it
being a big pain in the butt though
and so i yeah i edited i think yeah
every single way that you can edit i
think i've tried
and now i'm getting further and further
away from it because i'm
you know shooting i have a few directors
well
maybe not even a few maybe just a couple
who involve me in the edit
but usually i shoot and then that's it i
don't see it again until it's time for
color
but some directors will send me rough
cuts and ask for some my thoughts and
i love that because i i consider that
all part of my job the rhythm of a
sequence and how it feels how it
progresses
i'm i i love talking to editors
uh rather directors in terms of editing
i think talking to a director about
editing
how a sequence will come together tells
you
uh a bit about the tone like starting
wide ending up close something as basic
as that but
the movement of a thing is the sequence
going to end static are we gonna do we
want the whole thing to
so so for me editing is very connected
to cinematography
uh which is dangerous because often i'm
kept out of that part of it
so yeah how has the rhythm changed over
the years i know you said earlier that
you
were able to get a big screen tv and
you're you love watching the film grain
of old movies
but how is the rhythm from old movies to
now changed
yeah i think a lot about rhythm of
modern film versus
versus older films because you know
audiences
are we're we're used to montage we're
used to i mean you you see a
30-second commercial now can have
i mean i don't i don't even know how to
hazard a guess i mean it could have 300
cuts in it you know like it
but audiences are savvy so they can take
that in
the question is you know what is
helping your message a bit more i have
over the last few years and this is the
influence i think of a specific director
i worked with charles
hood he is very aware of
when edits come and
he he has really influenced how i think
of it is
there there's some kind of a quote it
might be walter merch and i'm sure i'm
butchering it
but every cut every time you cut you're
letting the audience
off the hook so it's sort of this idea
of as
you know a scene is even if it's just
dialogue just two people talking
if you're able to block it out in such a
way or just a
you know walk and talk they're walking
and you're just the camera's leading
if you can let that shot linger
it seems to me that you're more invested
in the in the scene and as soon as it
starts cutting
and then it cuts and then it cuts and it
cuts that
it's it's being almost pieced together
later
and i do think there's something about
that that
i don't know it almost reminds you that
you're watching a film or something
whereas when
shots are longer and you hold for longer
which is hard to do because that can get
very boring
but if you can block a scene well and
you know the actors in conjunction with
the camera
and they sort of you can land in a
close-up and then this actor moves here
and they go
and the camera moves you it's it's a
dance
and if that's choreographed well i i
think
that's about the best that you can do is
fewer cuts and
and a part of it is also watching
filmmakers who i love like paul thomas
anderson somebody i love one of the
great filmmakers working he does not cut
a ton he he let he lets the scenes
breathe
but that's you know that's not for
everyone it's not to say it's right or
wrong
but in terms of keeping people in
in the story that's something that i
think helps i think that's a
tool that really helps people stay
engaged
is fewer cuts now we'll see how i feel a
few years from now but
currently that's something that i'm
trying to get better at is
choreography
you